I'm having a great deal of knee, joint, and leg paid.
Can I add myomid?
It's myomid, I think.
My doctor, she, to my protocol of astroclear,
aroma clear, and so forth as I'm three times a day,
also will the Dutch test results give an indication
of what I need to increase or decrease what I'm taking.
So you can add myomid, it has a lot of the same things in it.
So, I don't know why you necessarily want to,
but if you just feel like that's what you're supposed to do,
then byomids, you can.
Will the Dutch test results give an indication
of what I need to increase or decrease what you're taking?
Yes, it can.
I did this person who asked this question.
I did send you your Dutch test results,
and everything was really good.
So, I don't know that I would change things.
I don't know that I would add myomid.
You know, I don't think that's gonna improve it even more.
Everything was where it's supposed to be.
So, if you need to go over that,
I think you're already scheduled next week.
So we'll talk about it.